200 km de métro 72 nouvelle gare depuis
la semaine dernière et les annonces du
premier ministre jean marc ayrault le
grand paris est à nouveau sur les rails
même s'il faudra attendre plus longtemps
et qu'il coûtera surtout plus cher avant
d'écouter dans un instant la réaction de
françois de mazières le député maire
divers droite de versailles voici un
rappel des principales annonces ce qu'il
faut attendre du projet notamment dans
le département désigné grand paris
express est mort vive le nouveau grand
paris jean marc ayrault a donc tranché
mercredi oui le projet de transport de
banlieue à banlieue initié par nicolas
sarkozy verra bien le jour
mais il coûtera plus cher et les travaux
seront plus longs dans le détail deux
cents kilomètres de lignes vont voir le
jour ainsi que 72 gares
le coût global est de 29,5 milliards
d'euros contre 20 milliards initialement
annoncé le financement n'est pas
totalement finalisé il se fera par une
redistribution de certaines taxes
touchant les entreprises et aussi par
une contribution de plusieurs millions
des collectivités locales mais le
premier ministre a aussi évoqué la
possibilité d'augmenter les amendes
forfaitaires de stationnement de 17 à 35
euros
concernant le département des yvelines
des ajustements été opérées sur le
projet initial l'ancienne ligne verte a
été baptisé ligne 18
elle reliera versailles chantiers massy
palaiseau en passant par saint quentin
en yvelines et ne sera achevé qu'en 2030
l'aménagement sera plus léger un métro
sur pneus un tram train et un métro
aérien
cette ligne 18 permettra en tout cas de
desservir saclay appelé à devenir un
pôle de compétitivité incontournable
avec ses entreprises et ses centres de
recherche et de formation
l'enjeu est de taille avec ses
réalisations le gouvernement entend
permettre à la région de rivaliser avec
les principaux pôles économiques
mondiaux en réduisant les temps de
déplacement les réactions qui sont
mitigés depuis l annonce qui laisse
différentes annonces qui ont été faites
réactions mitigées dans le département
si on se satisfait du maintien du projet
le financement est encore incertain et
le choix de l'échéance de 2030 pose
toujours question nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de françois de mazières député
maire de versailles il est forcément
concernés par ce grand paris lui qui a
suivi le dossier est depuis de
nombreuses années de très près dès son
lancement par nicolas sarkozy françois
de mazières était alors président de la
cité de l'architecturé
nous sommes donc avec le député maire de
versailles bonjour françois de mazières
merci de me recevoir dans votre hôtel de
ville on va parler donc du nouveau grand
paris puisque c'est dorénavant comme ça
qu'il faut appeler ce projet le nouveau
grand paris votre réaction qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas tardé vous dites c'est de
la poudre aux yeux et c'est dans le
communiqué que vous avez publié la
semaine dernière ça ne tient pas compte
des enjeux de la population de
développement économique également on va
rentrer dans les détails déjà pourquoi
ce premier sentiment que vous avez dans
ce premier sentiment c'est didier soulet
et importe en effet kim ho que l'on
réaffirme le principe de la double
boucle et notamment la boucle verte qui
nous intéresse dire celle qui fait orly
et 2018 qui devient dès qu'ils arrivent
jusqu'à versailles chantiers
là où je dis c'est ya pas beaucoup de
changements pour les yvelines c'est que
le calendrier le pire qu'on avait pu
envisager c'est 2030
effectivement on nous dit ça sera 2030
et après donc c'est bien
aujourd'hui on n'abandonne pas le projet
mais en fond je crois que personne
n'avait en tête qu'ils soient vraiment
abandonné à partir du moment où il ya
indispensable pour le plateau de saclay
et le sac plateau saclay est une très
grosse opération qui est vraiment lancée
maintenant avec des universités qui vont
arriver et l'enjeu vaut c'était en gros
de dire quand ça va être fait entre
saclay versailles et là malheureusement
ne dit quand vous serez les derniers ça
va ralentir le développement économique
de la zone ça peut freiner cette partie
là du grand paris c'est le vrai problème
pour nous c'est le financement
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui les
entreprises de la ville nouvelle de
saint quentin comme de versailles sont
appelés à financer la construction du
métro du grand paris de façon importante
vous avez au contraire des villes qui
vont bénéficier du métro et qui elles ne
donneront pas un sou parce qu'elles sont
considérées comme en plus grande
difficulté nous malheureusement on est
considéré comme
les zones qui ont un potentiel important
donc on est taxé et en même temps on
nous dit le métro viendra mais il
viendra te fera dans ces entreprises que
vous avez rencontrées avec qui vous avez
changé sur ce bassin de versailles de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'en inquiète
pour répartir sur d'autres zones
patrick s vous voulez que il ya deux
choses et les entreprises qui sont
installés pour elles c'est une change
ensuite elles vont donc faire un bilan
coût avantage le fait du déménagement
coûte cher mais par contre vous vous
songez aux entreprises nouvelle qui
devrait s'installer alors là je peux
vous dire façon extrêmement concrètes
aujourd'hui nous avons en gros ici
lorsque vous êtes propriétaire d'un
terrain une ville propriétaire d'un
terrain benjamin ville de versailles
elle veut vendre ce terrain il est
évident que elle va pas brader le
terrain est bien en gros si vous faites
du logement vous allez récupérer
aujourd'hui pratiquement quatre à cinq
fois plus pour le mètre carré il sera a
bondi de 4 femmes plus cher si vous et
logement plutôt que l'activité
économique
tout simplement parce que vous avez non
seulement le fait que l'on vend moins
cher
si vous faites de l'activité économique
plutôt que du logement mais en plus vous
avez la taxation pour les mètres carrés
qui sont construits pour du bureau voilà
ça fait beaucoup mais alors quelle
alternative quelles solutions possibles
en tant que député d'opposition est ce
que vous pouvez encore vous faire
entendre on a entendu beaucoup valérie
pécresse aussi alors nous si vous voulez
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que donc il y
aura ce métro prévue 2030 pour qu'il
soit fait déjà parce que je faisais
quand on est sur des des dates aussi
lointaine on a un peu peur de se dire
bon on a fait la promesse à coûte pas
grand chose à faire
et puis on verra plus tard donc nous mon
hockey on annonce date qui est pour nous
trop tard et on veut être sûr qu'elles
soient tenues
deuxième élément c'est que dit
2030 il faut avoir des mesures on va
dire moi lourde financièrement sans
plaider museo de jans comeau désenclaver
le plateau de satory
comment améliorer ses les liens qui sont
aujourd'hui compliquée entre
l'université de versailles saint quentin
qui a deux pôles le pôle de versailles
le polo saint quentin et vous savez
c'est pas simple ce sont les questions
concrètes sur lequel il faut réfléchir
avec toutes les annonces qui ont été
faites également la question du logement
aussi a été évoqué c'est l'acte 2 du
grand paris en dehors des transports
jean marc ayrault qui a rappelé 70000
logements neufs par an avec une cible
privilégiée les classes moyennes ça
c'est une bonne perspective aussi ça
concerne le logement le développement
sur votre secteur par exemple je crois
que tout le monde est d'accord pôle
logement mais il en revient toujours la
même chose
comment voulez vous alors nous qui
habitons sur cette zone
comment voulez-vous aujourd'hui imaginer
avec déjà les au comblement qu'il ya sur
tous les axes de circulation que l'on
voit le nombre des logements croître de
façon très important sans qu'on ait au
préalable posé la question des
transports et des transports en commun
et c'est ça notre problématique sur le
calendrier
70000 logements dont une partie sur
l'ouest de l'île de france
pourquoi pas mais donnons nous les
moyens de le faire et là si vous voulez
vous j'ai une vraie préoccupation c'est
que nous avons aujourd'hui par exemple
son avis versailles et vers 5 ans pas
qu'un problème de fond c'est le foncier
disponible ra sauver comme la nôtre le
fond c'est même très cher et le premier
propriétaire c'est l'état alors l'état a
voté une loi en disant va mobiliser les
terrains de l'état mais je vois très
concrètement mois soit 1 qu'est ce qui
se passe ici à versailles il y a des
anciennes danses un terrain où des
immeubles appartenant à l'étang qui sont
vendus il va qu'on l'état mort
aujourd'hui il met pas la clause et 25%
logements sociaux et moi je dis
concrètement comment voulez vous qu'on
arrive à faire nous ville où nous sommes
déjà à presque 18% le jeu
sociaux va passer la règle et 25% mais
si l'état quand il vend ses terrains
n'intègre pas la contrainte et 25 cents
logements sociaux c'est pas possible
donc il faut commencer à ce que les
temps montre l'exemple et quand ils
voient un terrain prévoient la clause
des 25% logements sociaux et auquel cas
on arrivera à avoir une politique qui
soit totalement cohérente mais c'est
peut-être un peu plus de technique là
mais y'a une création normalement d'une
commission zone urbaine de paris qui va
être mise en place avec les présidents
des intercommunalités
effectivement c'est un peu plus
technique mais vous en pensez quoi
j'en pense qu'il pouvait à tous et aux
grands machins oui c'est ce que je
remarque c'est que aujourd'hui parce que
ça permettrait d' impliquer les élus
peut-être un peu plus face sur tout ce
que je vois c'est que les élus
véritables responsables politiques du
logement ce sont les maires et là on est
en train de faire des grandes réunions
mais que c'est quoi ces grandes réunions
concrètement la gestion de l'urbanisme
elle est faite au niveau des mairies que
l'on laisse les mairies travailler et
les maires ne sont pas 10 est
responsable les maires savent qu'ils ont
besoin de toutes sortes de type de
logement alors on arrivera à être
efficaces mais là on crée des
commissions sans arrêt et chaque fois on
en crée une issue parlementaire moi même
je suis député je suis affolée par les
grecs en train d'imposer chaque fois
vous avez une nouvelle commission essaie
d heures perdues et vous avez une
nouvelle compétence et on sait plus qui
fait quoi
donc là ce qui m'ennuie et dans nouveau
projet de loi sur l'acte iii
décentralisation il ya un nombre de
commissions qui sont créés qui est
absolument incroyable
donc soyons simples l'esu travailler les
gens laissons les villes exercer leurs
fonctions et là je pense qu'on avancera
et la présentation du projet de loi de
décentralisation c'est le 10 avril
normalement socialisé le conseil des
ministres merci françois de mazières
pour ces précisions je rappelle votre
point de vue sur ce projet du nouveau
grand paris vous l'avez évoqué c'est un
projet déséquilibré vous venez nous
expliquer aujourd'hui poursuit de
calandre il son calendrier principe
ah c'est vous et pour conclure sur ce
dossier du nouveau grand paris vous avez
la parole que pensez vous de ce projet
va-t-il changer votre quotidien micro
trottoir à suivre et dans un instant
dans une minute le sport le 7-8 sport
comme chaque lundi anthony rech et ses
invités 4l trophy et cauterets et
notamment au programme nouveau grand
paris c'est vrai qu'on est un peu
éloigné nous ici mais pourquoi pas si on
y va plus facilement si c'est plus
facile à joindre tous les quartiers
déjà si ici on était un petit peu mieux
desservis ça serait pas mal
c'est pas une mauvaise chose simplement
il falloir respecter l'environnement
ce sera aidée à l'extérieur il y aurait
peut-être pu faire mieux une étude
j'allais dire plus souterraine voilà que
je trouve que la circulation est trop
importante et saturé dans la région et
je pense que ça a erré beaucoup et voilà
je suis tout à fait pour je pense que
c'est comme sans parler enfin circuler
plus facilement de montigné apparaît
justement c'est la suite aux galères on
doit aller par exemple jusqu'à la
défense pour ensuite circuler dans paris
donc je pense que c'est utile et qui va
permettre la ville de développer un peu
plus aussi que nous parlons de transport
une dernière information le trafic est
toujours perturbé sur la ligne c du rer
les lignes paris plaisir grignon en
cause un défaut d'alimentation
électrique à porsche fontaine est les
trains reliant à saint martin des tempes
à saint quentin en yvelines sont un
terminus viroflay rive gauche ou
chaville vélizy le trafic aussi perturbé
sur la ligne u la verrière la défense et
la ligne n plaisir grignon paris les
trains sont supprimés un service de bus
est mis en place entre plaisir et dreux
également plaisir et et paul meyer avec
desserte des gares intermédiaires retour
à une situation normale au cours de la
soirée aux alentours de 21h ce lundi on
passe aux sports à présent